can religious leaders please stop being
pedos but the Dalai Lama didn't want to
do that he wants young boys to kiss him
on the lips and suck his tongue and I
think that's disgusting I'm a Catholic
and that's cultural appropriation the
Catholic church had the same business
model as the BBC funded by the public
for the public and then they naunt their
kids everyone's offended when white
people appropriate other cultures but
the Dalai Lama takes our thing and no
one seems to mind it's a disgrace and
the worst bit about it was is that he
did it in full view of the camera like
an amateur that's why he got caught if
he was Catholic this stuff would be done
around the back of the altar like a
professional no one would have found out
about it there'd be no Scandal and
that's why it takes six years to train
as a priest